[Music]
it's time to write last woke it's time
to play spill your guts
Oh fill your guts so answer a question
or be forced to eat a questionable snack
like a cow's tongue or a
thousand-year-old egg from best to worst
in bed no but this is working on the
notion that they're all good no run John
Mayer Diplo and Orlando Bloom okay he
first tried to dodge the question
they're all amazing love who fail I
wanna have sex with all of them after I
get out of this then dropped this
shocker about singer Josh growth and
Josh Groban's in there I'm skating yeah
people are like who's the one that got
away about yeah that's good is he still
is a single boy no he's like one of my
good friends Katie and Josh were briefly
linked together in 2009 she released her
song the one that got away in 2010
but Gordon wouldn't let Goethe get away
with not answering
I think Diplo's third I do I do because
I think there's a reason people gump
become DJs so let's go Diplo yes
Diplo and Kati dated for less than a
month back in 2014 so it's not super
surprising she put him third but who
wins between most recent Expo Orlando
Bloom and on-again off-again love John
Mayer and then mayor then blue bloom
then man Oh
so John gets the win but everybody gets
complement you're listening to me
gentlemen I love you and you know that I
love you and it's not about that it's
just maybe I just haven't had enough
time to have sex with you so maybe we
can make up that time for sure nobody
was this ex with me now
[Music]
you